no voice mail today I want to tell you
that the david pakman show is hiring i
always say when we are hiring i will
announce it on the show we have a new
position which is sort of going to be
its initially going to be a part-time
marketing and outreach position it's
going to handle social media it's going
to handle new marketing and outreach
it's going to handle advertiser outreach
and advertiser relations the position
will be based here in our boston
massachusetts studio and it will be a
part-time position that will it'll have
to overlap with our current studio
production schedule right which is
monday through thursday during business
hours the position would be here in our
studio on at least three of those days
during business hours the ideal person
would be independent very good attention
to detail and this comes this includes
writing spelling grammar contacts in tax
etc comfortable talking to all sorts of
different types of people throughout the
day bringing new ideas for promotion to
the show comfortable making financial
proposals to advertisers if you're
interested in finding out more and in
applying please send in your resume
david at david pakman.com send a resume
as well as a cover letter that addresses
both how your experience would relate to
the job and you're sort of relationship
to progressive media and the david
pakman show so again part time position
based in our studio in boston social
media marketing outreach advertiser
outreach and advertiser relations to
apply send in your resume and a cover
letter which addresses your experience
in relation to the job and your relation
to progressive media and the david
pakman show on the bonus show today
massive storm going on outside today
okay i'm going to talk to you about that
i will talk to you about how the david
pakman show staff adjusted to the
weather today and about some of the
other things that are going on great
bonus show today sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership the coupon
code is available i voted 17 gives you a
major major discount off of membership
that's it for today talk to you on the
bonus show